-Welcome, welcome,
welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here, you made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
This morning,
the world's richest man,
Elon Musk, was named "Time"
magazine's Person of the Year.
Yeah.
Musk received the honor
for his work
in space exploration
and after he bought
10 million subscriptions
to "Time" magazine.
[ Laughter ]
I'm kidding.
Although it was a little strange
that everyone at "Time"
drove into work today
in a brand-new Tesla.
[ Laughter ]
Being named Person of the Year
is a big deal.
It's basically
Sexiest Man Alive,
but you're competing against
the Dalai Lama and the Pope.
[ Laughter ]
It was actually
a pretty competitive year.
The other finalists
were the scientists
behind the COVID vaccine
and the lawyer who appeared
at a Zoom trial
with a cat filter.
-Can you hear me, Judge?
I'm here live.
I'm not -- I'm not a cat.
[ Laughter ]
-Some news from Washington.
Today, President Biden signed
an executive order aimed at
improving customer experience
for government services,
like renewing passports
and filing taxes.
Yeah, now when you get audited,
the IRS agent
draws a little smiley face
on your return.
[ Laughter ]
And this is nice.
Now, when you're on hold
for two hours,
instead of light jazz,
they play even lighter jazz.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I saw that former
Vice President Mike Pence
has been touring key election
states, like New Hampshire.
A lot of people think
that he could be gearing up
for a presidential run in 2024.
He's even been testing out
some campaign slogans
to see what people respond to.
Check some of these out.
First up, there's "Pence 2024 --
I make Mitt Romney
look like Post Malone."
[ Laughter ]
Next, there's "Pence 2024 --
I call ketchup hot sauce."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
there's "Pence 2024 --
One time, I heard
a Megan Thee Stallion song
and fainted."
[ Laughter ]
I think that's the one.
-Wow, yeah! That's the one.
-"Mother!"
-Oh, I heard that,
in a new documentary,
Russian President Vladimir Putin
revealed that, back in the '90s,
he worked as a cab driver
to make ends meet.
Yep, it was the only cab
where you got in
and the driver told you
where you're going.
[ Laughter ]
"We're taking detour."
[ Light laughter ]
It was the last time Putin
drove a car
where the "passenger"
wasn't in the trunk.
[ Laughter, scattered groans ]
Hey, this is cool --
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Listen to this.
New FDA-approved eye drops
just hit the market
that provide better vision
for up to 10 hours.
And they could replace
reading glasses
for millions of Americans.
Yeah, which means your dad
will now walk around
looking for the eye drops that
are on the top of his head.
[ Laughter ]
"Where did I put --"
You know some guy's
gonna be like,
"I bet if I use the whole
bottle, I could see Mars."
[ Laughter ]
Now when you notice someone
putting in eye drops,
you can play the fun new game,
"Reader or Stoner?"
It's cool. It's fun.
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this --
authorities in New Zealand
are investigating after one man
apparently got
10 COVID vaccine shots
on the same day
and pretended to be
a different person each time.
[ Laughter ]
If you asked what he got,
he says, "Johnson and Johnson
and Johnson and Johnson
and Johnson and Johnson."
[ Laughter ]
It was weird at his office
holiday party when he was like,
"So, how did you guys
feel after the ninth dose?
That one kind of got me."
You guys hear about this?
A Michigan woman is currently
facing up to nine years
in prison
after she went to a fake website
called "Rent-A-Hitman"
and offered $5,000 to have
her ex-husband killed.
Yeah, you could tell
she was nervous.
Today, she logged into
Bribe-A-Judge.org.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, this is big.
Last night the January 6th
commission revealed that
during the Capitol riots,
the White House Chief of Staff
got texts pleading for Trump
to calm things down
from Fox News anchors
and Donald Trump Jr.
[ Audience murmurs ]
Yeah.
Trump ignored the advice
of the closest to him
and also Don Jr.
[ Laughter ]
Trump was like, "If I replied
to every text that said
'What you're doing is crazy,'
I'd never get anything done."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it came out
that Fox News hosts
were begging Trump
to do something.
And today, Fox News hosts
lit their tree on fire again
just to change the subject.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Trump didn't want to hear it.
Not only did he ignore the texts
from Fox News,
he also dropped them from
his family cellphone plan.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, White House
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows was
getting texts during the attack
asking Trump to intervene.
For example, Sean Hannity
texted -- and this is real --
"Can he make a statement, ask
people to leave the Capitol?"
Yep, that's not all Meadows
received.
Several other messages that day
too.
For example, Eric Trump texted,
"Head stuck in Capitol
staircase railing.
Send help!"
[ Laughter ]
Next up, Rudy Giuliani texted,
"Just showed up
at Capitol Total Landscaping.
When's the riotin' start?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally President Trump
texted Meadows,
"Just make sure they don't take
away my Twitter!"
Yeah, there you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Crazy day all around.
[ Applause ]
Some more news from Washington.
The White House just announced
their plan to add
500,000 charging stations
for electric vehicles
across the country.
It's incredible.
Somehow we can build half
a million charging stations,
but we can't add a second outlet
at LaGuardia.
[ Laughter ]
Can I charge my phone?
I just -- Okay.
You guys hear this?
Today, the state of New York
ordered former governor
Andrew Cuomo to return
the $5 million he received from
his book on leadership
during the pandemic.
I think it's safe
to say the drinking
at the Cuomo family Christmas
has already begun.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news -- After
announcing their name change,
Facebook paid a bank
in South Dakota
$60 million for the rights
to their new name, Meta.
It's making me emotional because
seeing a bank get $60 million
is what Christmas is all about.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
That's right, a bank.
Now they're so rich,
they don't even chain
their pens to the table anymore.
[ Laughter ]
"Just take them!
That's a Montblanc.
Just take it."
I like how Facebook
was trying to rename
their company something "cool,"
but it was already being used
by a bank in South Dakota.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is encouraging.
I read that despite
supply chain issues,
UPS and the Postal Service
have improved their on-time
deliveries compared to
last year's holiday season.
That's right.
They now deliver
that little slip that says,
"Sorry we missed you"
right on time.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Right on time.
"Ah, I was here all day."
I saw that LG has a new
battery-powered TV that you can
wheel around on a stand
to watch anywhere.
Yeah, a TV on wheels.
It is perfect
if you've ever dreamt of being
a substitute teacher from 1997.
[ Laughter ]
And get this -- Uber Eats just
made its first-ever delivery
to space after a Japanese
billionaire brought food
from the app to astronauts on
the International Space Station.
That's how tough the economy is
right now --
a billionaire is working
for Uber Eats.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is interesting.
A new study found that
rocket scientists
and brain surgeons
are not any smarter
than the general population.
[ Laughter ]
That's got to be a great study
to read right before
you're wheeled in
for brain surgery, right?
It's like, "Huh?"
Brain surgeons were like, "You
need to be super smart to know
about the brain and all those
little tubey things around it."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a woman eating at
a restaurant in New Orleans
found a dozen pearls in
an oyster that she ordered.
[ Audience murmurs ]
The woman said she would
probably sell the pearls
when they passed
in six to eight hours.
Today, Chinese President
Xi Jinping met virtually
with Russian President
Vladimir Putin.
They didn't talk, even.
They just spent an hour
exchanging maniacal laughter.
[ Laughing evilly ]
It's not great news for Biden.
I mean, for Marvel fans,
it's like if Spider-Man
found out that Doc Ock
was Zooming
with the Green Goblin.
I mean, something is happening.
[ Laughter ]
But they had a lot to discuss,
like trade, nuclear arms,
and why Carrie
didn't call 9-1-1.
[ Laughter ]
At one point,
Xi called Putin his old friend,
and Putin called Xi
his dear friend.
Then they ended the call like,
"You hack us first,"
"No, you hack us first!"
"Oh, no, you hack us first!"
[ Laughter ]
Some big news in Washington.
The House voted to hold
former Trump chief of staff
Mark Meadows
in criminal contempt of Congress
for refusing to cooperate
with the January 6th panel.
The consequences are severe.
Meadows could be sentenced
to a year in prison,
or, even worse,
another month working for Trump.
[ Laughter ]
Of course,
Meadows needs a good lawyer,
so the first thing he did
was pull up
Rudy Giuliani's number
and delete it.
[ Laughter ]
Some more news.
The White House just announced
that, due to COVID concerns,
instead of the traditional
holiday parties,
it's inviting guests
to come see the decorations
on a 30-minute self-guided tour.
[ Light laughter ]
Which is just a fancy way
of Biden saying,
"Come if you want,
but I ain't gonna be there."
[ Laughter ]
"I ain't getting COVID."
[ Light laughter ]
So guests can now go
on a 30-minute self-guided tour
of an old mansion.
There's actually a name
for that --
it's called a haunted house.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
A self-guided tour
of a historic
Washington building.
That's basically how Fox News
described January 6th.
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this -- I heard that
pharmacists across the country
are feeling burned out
due to increased demand
for COVID shots
and being short-staffed.
Yeah, I'm sure it's that
and not just hearing
The Chipmunks Christmas on loop
for two months.
It's like, "I'm losing it, Gary.
I'm losing it.
Get him a hula hoop!
Get him a hula hoop!"
[ Laughter ]
You know your pharmacist
is stressed out
when they disinfect your arm
with the Bacardi
from their flask.
"Shot for you, shot for me,
right?"
[ Laughter ]
It's gotten so bad now,
when you order Xanax,
the pharmacist says,
"We just ran out."
[ Laughter ]
Get this.
In Canada, a 5-year-old is safe
after he was caught driving
his parents' car
to go buy a Christmas present
for his sister.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
The cop asked him to recite
the alphabet backwards,
and he was like, "I haven't even
learned it forwards."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, he's in a lot of trouble,
so, really, his sister got
the greatest gift of all.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the kid showed
each officer a packet
of Dunkaroos and said,
"How about we, uh,
say this never happened?"
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, this is something
you don't hear every day.
Authorities in Ohio
are investigating
after someone stole
a 58-foot bridge.
[ Light laughter ]
Police say they're
on the lookout for a thief
who's described
as having dark hair,
blue eyes, and is the Hulk.
Well, guys, one of the biggest
movies of the year,
"Spider-Man: No Way Home"
has finally hit theaters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally.
Fans are going nuts.
People haven't been this pumped
for a Marvel movie
since the last one
came out a week ago.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, everyone's excited
to see it in theaters.
Even Dr. Fauci was like,
"Screw it.
I got to support this guy."
[ Laughter ]
"He's wearing a mask.
Let's go. I'm ready to go."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, as we speak,
fans are lined up
to see the movie,
including plenty of guys
dressed like Spider-Man
who definitely can't pull off
dressing like Spider-Man.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
In this movie,
Spider-Man has to fight off
a bunch of crazy villains
at once.
And after he does,
he's immediately hired
as a flight attendant
for United.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of airlines,
in a Senate hearing,
the CEOs of Southwest
and American Airlines
both questioned the need
for masks on planes.
Yep, the same thing
actually happened last month
with the CEO of Spirit
and pants.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the Southwest CEO was
like, "Who needs masks?
There's plenty of fresh air.
We fly with the top down."
"Buckle up, everybody!"
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of wearing masks
on planes, I heard about
one passenger who tried
to work around the rule.
Listen to this.
-A man is now banned from flying
with United Airlines
after deciding to mask up
with a bright red thong.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-If you fly Spirit,
that's the oxygen mask
that drops down in an emergency.
[ Laughter ]
Make sure to put it
on yourself first, then...
[ Laughter ]
-"Dumps like a truck."
-A few minutes later,
an air marshal walked over
and gave him a mouth wedgie.
It was interesting.
[ Laughter ]
You guys see this?
Former President Trump
is really upset with his old
chief of staff Mark Meadows
for writing in his book
that Trump's hair
looked awful when he had COVID.
[ Laughter ]
Must have looked really bad,
because that's how most people
describe Trump's hair
when he's healthy.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, I read
that this holiday season,
Melania Trump is releasing
her first NFT,
called "Melania's Vision,"
which is a watercolor
of her eyes.
[ Laughter ]
Donald's like,
"I'm so proud of you.
Congrats on the 'nuft.'"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump's excited about it.
He thinks NFT stands
for "not filing taxes."
[ Laughter and applause ]
The cool thing
about Melania's NFT,
just like she does
with her husband,
as soon as you turn away,
the eyes roll.
[ Laughter ]
It's amazing.
Hey, this is cool.
In a recent interview,
Usain Bolt said
that playing "Mario Kart"
helped him become
an Olympic champion.
[ Cheers ]
I'm in shock.
'Cause apparently I've been
training for the Olympics
for the last 35 years.
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this.
Here in New York, an MTA manager
was caught with the blow-up doll
in the front seat of his car,
and he's insisting that
he uses it for the company
and not so that he can drive
in the carpool lane.
[ Laughter ]
In a related story, he's lying.
Guy was like, "Look,
if you have a problem with this,
talk to my lawyer," and then,
he blew up another doll.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, guys, "Sing 2"
is coming out next week.
I mean,
we are excited about this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It has such an amazing cast,
and we wanted to do something
fun with the actors.
So we gave them a bunch
of weird phrases
and asked them to sneak those
phrases into their interviews
as casually as possible.
No one knew we were doing this.
So check it out.
It's time for "Drop It In."
-♪ Drop It In, Drop It In ♪
♪ D-D-D-D-Drop It In, yeah ♪
-Obviously, everyone's going
to watch "Sing 2" for Christmas.
How do you guys plan on
celebrating Christmas
this year?
-I'm just going to eat
a lot of food, I feel like,
'cause, you know,
you know what they say --
if you can't lick the spoon,
just eat the bowl, you know?
-That's right.
-Which of the following
is not a marsupial --
kangaroo, koala, or platypus?
-Koala.
-Platypus have no pouches.
They're the only
egg-laying mammal.
-Pouches, eggs,
grape nuts, go nuts.
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
-I think it's also a movie
about --
about overcoming your own
personal obstacles and --
I mean, even the Pringles Guy
gets lonely in January.
-How many "Sing" stories
do you want to tell?
Like, have you thought
of what you would write
for "Sing 3" or "Sing 4"?
-There could be a "Sing 3,"
"Sing 4," "Sing 5," "Sing 6,"
"Sing 7," "Sing 8" --
"Sing 8," yeah -- "Sing 9,"
"Sing 10," "Sing 11,"
-It'd be like the KIDZ BOP
version of movies!
-..."Sing 12." Yeah! I mean,
you'd skip 13 because of,
you know, bad vibes.
-Yeah, no, you can never...
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-But, no, I think, otherwise,
it could go on forever.
-So, this was obviously,
like, filming during the pand--
Did you guys get to get together
at any point?
-Oh!
They're g-r-r-rape!
As T the Tiger says.
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
They're g-r-rape!
-That's sort of the fun
of show business.
And the hard part is, you know,
you get ready, and then there's
someone who can tell you no,
and it's deflating, you know?
It's never a great idea
to microwave a balloon.
[ Ding ]
...and I think that the beauty
of this cast of characters is,
they don't stop.
-In the film, Buster Moon has
to tell a little white lie.
I'm curious to know
if you've ever had to exaggerate
a special skill to either land
a role or get ahead.
-I never will tell a white lie.
And that's something I learned
when I once
put a balloon
inside of a microwave,
and it's never a good idea to
put a balloon in a microwave.
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
I just have
one last thing to say.
Nunca es un buen idea poner
un globo en el microondo.
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
And that's something that is
really important to remember.
-[ Laughs ] Thank you
for sharing that tip with us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We are one week away
from Christmas.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just seven more days,
just eight more sleeps,
and 900 more Hallmark movies.
That's it.
We're almost there.
That's right, we're one week
away from Christmas.
Or as the Panera gift cards
at Walgreens call it,
"Our time to shine."
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Christmas is just
seven days away,
which means that you'll finish
your chocolate advent calendar
in...10 days ago.
[ Laughter ]
At this point, everyone's
advent calendar
is starting to look like
an abandoned Motel 6.
It's sort of sad.
[ Laughter ]
But you can tell the whole city
is in the holiday spirit.
I mean, right now,
Times Square Elmo
reeks of eggnog
instead of vodka.
And that just...
Get this, guys.
According to a new poll,
this year a majority of people
started their Christmas shopping
before November.
[ Audience murmurs ]
Mostly because nobody's known
what month it is
since March 2020.
[ Laughter ]
I saw in a recent survey that
most Americans would rather
get an experience than a gift.
Well, their partner's gonna be
like, "Well, now you can enjoy
the experience of owning socks.
There you go."
[ Laughter ]
This is amazing --
Experts predict that
by the end of January,
$120 billion worth of gifts
will be returned.
Yep, on Christmas morning,
we exchange presents,
and on Christmas afternoon,
we exchange receipts.
[ Laughter ]
I read that this year's top
toy gifts include
the Magic Mixies
Magical Misting Cauldron
and WowWee's Got2Glow
Fairy Finder.
-Ooh, nice.
Did you get either one of those?
-No, I ended up not going for
a Magic Mixies
Magical Misting Cauldron
or WowWee's Got2Glow
Fairy Finder.
But I did consider getting
the World of Wacky Wonder
Wizard Worms.
-Not the Nerdy Naughty Gnomes?
-Well, I was tempted by
the Enchanting Earl's
Underwater Otter Oasis,
but I'd be lying if I said
I didn't think about picking up
some Charming Chucky Enchanted
Choo-Choo Train Chomping Chimps.
-Ooh. I love those.
Are those made by the same
people who made the toad one?
-Talking about
Twiggy the Trendy Twitter Toad
or Tommy the Ticklish
Texas Toad?
-Either one.
-They're both sold out.
-Oh.
-They only had Talented Tacky's
Tasteful Tap-dancing Tank-diving
Turtle Taxis.
And Fabulously Fancy Foamy
Fluffy the Fantastic Fighting
French Falcon.
-Those are good options,
but I also hear the best toy
of the year is the --
-Bawitdaba Da Bang Da Dang
Diggy Diggy Shake Up the Boogie
Said Up Jump the Boogie Dogs?
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, I heard that, too.
[ Chuckles ] Anyway, what are
you getting your kids this year?
-Uhhh, gift card to Dunkin'.
[ Laughter ]
-Me too!
-Oh, my God!
[ Applause ]
-Moving on.
This is very funny.
A woman in California
got into the holiday spirit
by turning her cubicle at work
into a gingerbread house.
This is real.
Check this out.
-Aw.
[ Audience murmurs ]
-It looks like one of those huts
where mall Santas go to vape
on their break.
[ Laughter ]
When they show around
new employees, they're like,
"And that's Carol.
She's...a lot."
[ Laughter ]
"She's...mm...
Yep."
Finally, I heard that this month
Mariah Carey's "All I Want
for Christmas Is You" became
the first holiday song
to hit 1 billion streams
on Spotify.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Even more impressive, those are
just streams from one CVS.